ever play fallout 1 or 2 how about old  school do more quake if the answer is no  you should probably head over to gog the  digital storefront run by CD Projekt is  having a massive sale on all bethesda  games don't be shy now chances are we  have whatever you're looking for there  are over a dozen titles available each  one is drm free and discounted between  66 and seventy-five percent off you want  more a win for seven bucks or doom for a  buck 50 now's your chance and no matter  what you buy you'll get the Elder  Scrolls arena and elder scrolls  daggerfall as a free bonus with any  purchase that all sounds tempting but  you'll only have until December 29th to  pick what you want I'm sure you've been  playing plenty of fallout 4 this season  and now you can experience the original  games and a whole lot more for dirt  cheap keep it locked to gamespot com for  all the best holiday deals from your  favorite retailers